>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> It is my pleasure to be here
to introduce Michael Buckley.
Michael Buckley started his career
actually of college dabbling
in journalism believe it or not and
then he got wise and decided to move
on and see if he could find
a more promising field.
So he became a pasta maker.
That didn't work out for him
so he decided to flip burgers,
still better than journalism.
So then he tried stand up and
he even sang in a punk band.
Maybe he'll do us a rendition.
Anyway eventually he ended up
on television and he worked
on a number of kid shows.
Luckily for us he never forgot
how much he really liked to write
or at least how good he was at it,
whether he liked to write or not.
And he is now as you
know the author of one
of the great book series there
is for kids, The Sisters Grimm,
in which the characters -- yes
you all know, much applause --
in which the fairytales that
you all know come to life.
It's won many awards and he has gone
on to write The N.E.R.D.S. books,
which I'm sure you have -- there
are fans in the audience too.
[Sound effects] So because you are
excited I can tell, you don't need
to hear me anymore, I am very
happy to introduce Michael Buckley.
[Applause]
>> Michael Buckley:
Hey, how are you.
Are you guys ready to rock?
I'm not really quite ready
to rock yet, but maybe later.
Thank you so much for
the great introduction.
I'm very happy to be here.
This is a big thrill
and a treat for me.
I write a couple of different
children's book series
like she said.
One is called The Sisters Grimm and
another one is called N.E.R.D.S.
And I thought I would tell
you a little bit about them
but I thought first I would tell
you about how I became an author.
It is a very exciting story
and it involves ninjas.
[Laughter] It doesn't
involve ninjas.
I'm sorry, that was a lie.
I was born in a little
town in Ohio called Akron.
Many of you yes [Sound effects]
the most boring place in the world.
The only exciting thing that ever
happened there is we invented
the zipper.
[Laughter] That was a big day.
We also have a race there
called The Soapbox Derby.
This is a race where we
put as small child in a box
and shove them down a hill.
[Laughter] So Akron
is fun on that day.
[Laughter] Now when I was a
kid I was really influenced
by standup comedians.
My older brother Jeff was a complete
degenerate and he would wake me
up in the middle of the night
to watch Saturday Night Live.
I was six.
[Laughter] I did not
understand it at all.
And he would force me to
listen to his comedy albums.
I grew up listening to like
Woody Allen and Steve Martin,
who is still one of my favorites.
And when I got to the age of
16 I decided that I wanted
to be a standup comedian too.
So I went to all of the comedy
clubs in Akron, which was one.
[Laughter] And I said, "I
want to be a comedian."
And they said, "You have
to be 18 to be a comedian."
And I said, "I am a18."
And they believed it,
because it was Akron.
[Laughter] Now I got to
tour all over the country.
I preformed with some
pretty famous comics.
There's a guy named John Stuart on
a show called The Daily Show, yes.
[Sound effects] I performed with a
guy named Dane Cook and another guy
from Ohio named Dave Chappele.
None of the children
should know who that is.
[Laughter] While I was
doing that I went to school.
I went to a college in southern
Ohio called Ohio University.
If you know football you
know Ohio State University.
If you know competitive checkers,
you know Ohio University.
[Laughter] I didn't
realize what she was doing.
Okay. That's very cool too.
What if I just talk to you and
see what comes out of your hands.
[Laughter] That's very good.
Now when I graduated
from college I went
to a placed called New York
City and I was an intern
on a show called The Late
Show with David Letterman.
I got to meet all kinds of famous
people, very glamorous people,
though my job on the
show was not glamorous.
I had to take care of David
Letterman's clinically insane
golden retriever.
He had a big, fat yellow
hairy meatball of rage
that would attack me all the time.
But if that dog wasn't murdering
me they would let me do something
really cool.
They would let me write a joke.
Now I had written my own jokes
for much smaller audiences
but the late show has about 10
million people watching it every
night so this was a
really big deal for me.
And I would write that joke on a
piece of paper and I'd hand it Dave
and I'd go hide behind the
curtain and look at the audience
like some kind of weirdo,
and every once in a while one
of my jokes would get a huge laugh.
I often tell kids the best way I can
describe how that felt was it felt
like I had a super power.
Because I had written a
few words on piece of paper
and it caused such a reaction.
I wondered if I could get people
to feel other things with words
like maybe I could make
them happy or sad or angry
or want to move out of Akron.
[Laughter] so that's kind of
how I got started as a writer.
I was lucky enough to get some
very decent jobs right off the bat.
I worked for a channel
called Discovery Channel.
This is the channel where people are
constantly being attacked by sharks.
[Laughter] I did a couple
of documentaries for them.
One was about the mole people who
are a group of people who live
in the New York City Subway system.
And I did another documentary
about sideshow performers.
And these are people who
swallow swords and eat fire
and put scorpions in their mouths.
Awesome. [Laughter] So I
got to hang out with people
who were completely covered
in tattoos and I met a person
who eats fire and I hung
out with a bearded lady.
She had a beard down
to here and we dated.
[Laughter] I'm kidding.
She wouldn't go out with me.
[Laughter] But I'm okay now.
After a while I went to work
for a channel called MTV.
That's probably what the kids
know as the educational channel.
[Laughter] I went to work for a
channel called VH1 for a little bit
and I did some work for a
channel called Nickelodeon.
[Laughter] Yes, my people.
And then I came up this idea
for a little book called
The Sisters Grimm.
And I want to tell you
a little bit about it.
It's about these two
girls who move to a town
where everyone is a
fairytale character.
Prince Charming is the mayor.
The three little pigs
run the police department
and the big bad wolf
is a yoga instructor.
[Laughter] And the girls
take on the family business
which is being a detective.
They discover that their
great, great, great, great,
great grandfather Jacob Grimm
and his brother Wilhelm
weren't writing fairytales.
They were writing case files
for their detective work.
So the girls kind of take on this
family business and what I love
about writing this series is
you never know who's going
to be a good guy or a bad guy.
Life for instance in book three, the
girls take on the most diabolical
and evil fairytale
character of all time.
Of course, I'm taking about
Little Red Riding Hood.
She's terribly evil and super scary.
[Laughter] I'm also writing
another series and that's kind
of why I was invited here.
It's a series called N.E.R.D.S.
[Sound effects] Thank you.
N.E.R.D.S. is an acronym.
It stands for the National
Espionage Rescue and Defense Society
and it takes place here
in Arlington, Virginia.
It's about a bunch of very
nerdy 5th graders who happen
to be secret agents and their
nerdy qualities have been enhanced
by science and they're basically
turned into super powers.
One of the kids has the worst
set of braces you have ever seen.
They wrap around his
head like an erector set
but he can manipulate
them like a transformer.
So if he needs a car, a
car comes out of his mouth
but it is still attached
to his teeth.
I think that's funny.
[Laughter] There's
a kid who has eaten
so much paste he can stick to walls.
And there's a little
girl there who's inspired
by my wife who has asthma.
Anybody here have asthma?
A few of you, yeah.
Well my wife has this
thing called an inhaler.
And she uses this to
make herself feel better.
She takes it her mouth and pulls the
plunger and this medicine goes go
into her lungs and every time I
heard her use it, it always sounded
like a little rocket to me.
So I created this character,
they call her Wheezer
and Wheezer has two inhalers
that allow her to fly.
She is sort of like a gasping
Iron Man, that kind of thing.
[Laughter] And there's a bunch
of other kids in the team.
The second book just came out.
It is called M is for Mama's Boy.
The villain is a 37 year old man
who lives in his mom's basement,
which is scarier than it sounds.
And one of things that I love to
do when I travel around the country
and I get to go to schools
and I come to conventions
like this I just love to tell
kids how much I love my job.
Like being a writer is
like the best job ever.
And I know because I
worked at Taco Bell
and that is not the best job ever.
And I was always trying to convince
kids to think of it as a career.
I think that once a kid gets a
book sometimes it's hard for them
to fathom that somebody
actually sat down and wrote this
and there's a real person behind it.
And I always try to
encourage them to think of it
as something they might want
to do when they get older.
Like I said being a writer
is like a blessing to me.
There's so many people in the
world that want to do that as job
and I'm one of the luck idiots
that gets to do it for a living.
And I want to thank all of you
guys, because every time you buy one
of my books you make it completely
possible for me to just hang
out in Starbuck's all day.
[Laughter] It if wasn't for you, I'd
have to put pants on in the morning.
Thank you so much.
You are my inspiration.
You're the wind beneath my wings.
[Sound effects] Thank you.
That's what I wanted
to be when I grew up.
A guy who did not wear pants and
it's working out pretty good.
[Laughter] So I know that
MT took some questions,
maybe I could do the same.
But I'm going to tell
you first of all,
unless you're a really attractive
kid, I don't want to hear from you.
[Sound effects] Okay you're really
cute so you can step right up.
>> What inspired you to
make The Sisters Grimm?
>> Michael Buckley: Well, you
now that's a very good question.
People ask me that all the time.
Why did I write The Sisters Grimm?
Well I'm going to tell you.
I went to a book store and I looked
at all the books that are out there
for kids and I realized there's only
like two kinds of books for kids.
There's books for boys where
the boy goes to wizarding school
and he rides a dragon
and he fights a monster.
And then there's books for girls
where they take care of a pony,
or they're dating a vampire.
[Laughter] That is all there is.
And I just looked at my nieces.
My brother has some kids, these
little girls and they are so spunky
and full of fun and
they're just so passionate.
And I just thought I
don't know any girls
that would take a pony
over a dragon ride.
And I thought it was about time
that girls got a book that they got
to save the world and do all the
cool stuff that boys get to do.
[Applause] Thank you.
But don't applaud me just yet.
But I wanted boys to read this
so I filled it full of boogers
and all kinds of gross stuff,
so this isn't John Steinbeck.
Yeah over there.
Oh another really good
looking kid, okay.
>> Oh, what's your
favorite children's book
that you didn't write?
>> Michael Buckley: Most
of them are so terrible.
They're all just nonsense.
[Laughter] No I think the single
biggest reason why I stand here
today is a kids book when I was
in the fourth grade I was what
they call a reluctant reader.
Back then they were
called a pain in the butt.
And the librarian dragged
me aside and she said,
"Mr. Buckley you're going to read
a book today and you're going
to tell me everything you know
about it at the end of the week."
And she shoved a book in my
hand and it was called The Mouse
and the Motorcycle and
it's by Beverly Cleary.
[Applause] Yes, and I had no
idea that books could be fun
because they would give us this
book every year called The Yearling.
Lovely book about a boy and his pet
deer and I kept waiting for the deer
to grow rockets or
something explode.
It never happened.
So that was a very refreshing
thing for me because I had no idea
that books could kind of just be --
well this is the highest compliment
that I can give Beverly Cleary.
That book is pointless and
that is exactly what I wanted
when I was a 9 year old boy, yeah.
Yes, oh yes this is a
very good looking kid.
Okay.
>> Who is your favorite
Sisters Grimm character?
>> Michael Buckley: Who is my
favorite Sisters Grimm character?
You know it's a character
that I didn't even want
to write about at first.
His name is Prince Charming.
And the reason that I like
writing about Prince Charming
and this character has
been done to death.
Most people have just killed
him and made him boring.
But I started to just
notice something about him.
Like Prince Charming
was born to save women.
He's supposed to get on a
white horse and rescue girls.
And what I like about him so much
is he's in love with somebody
who does not want to
be saved at all.
She can do it herself.
In fact Snow White in the story,
she's like a self-defense teacher.
She like -- she teaches old
ladies how to fend off robbers
and she doesn't need to be rescued
and I just think it's so interesting
to write this character who
was really born to be something
that the woman he loves
doesn't want anymore.
So he's sort of kind walking
around with absolutely no idea what
he's supposed to do with his life.
So that's my favorite
character to write.
Yeah. How about you?
A very handsome kid, yes.
>> I have two questions.
Number one what inspired
you for N.E.R.D.S.?
>> Michael Buckley: Well N.E.R.D.S.,
I went back to my 20th
high school reunion.
[Laughter] And this is an
important thing for all the kids.
Now I went back and I hadn't seen
some of my old friends in 20 years.
And what I discovered was all the
popular kids, the ones I wanted
to hang out with and I wanted
to go to their parties,
well they were losers,
but all of the N.E.R.D.S.,
the complete odd balls that I
wouldn't have been caught dead with,
they were doing amazing stuff.
I mean they were running companies.
They were traveling
all over the world.
A couple of them were
married to super models.
It was amazing.
So I wanted to write a book
that kind of lets the kids know
that the world does a flip flop.
Eventually you will be the
coolest person in the room even
if you are the biggest
nerd in the room right now.
It all gets spinned around.
[Applause] Look at me.
I was once very popular.
[Laughter] So maybe it
doesn't work in my case.
>> Who's your favorite
Sisters Grimm?
>> Michael Buckley: My favorite
Sisters Grimm book to write --
that I wrote was number five,
It's Magic and Other Misdemeanors.
And what I love about so
much is my favorite movie
of all time is Back to the Future.
And if they play that
on TBS, I'm watching it.
I watch it every time's it on.
And I wanted to write
a time travel story
and I had all these fairytale
characters and I thought,
"I wonder if anybody has ever
done that kind of thing."
So I really enjoyed writing that.
I love it also because
Cinderella is in it.
And Cinderella is sort
of a Dr. Laura.
She gives advice to people on
how to deal with their families
on the radio and I just enjoyed
writing about her and her husband.
So yeah number five
is my favorite one.
Alright.
>> Of the N.E.R.D.S. book that you
wrote which one is your favorite?
>> Michael Buckley: Which one's
the most expensive to buy?
[Laughter] That would
be the new one.
Number two.
You know what I'm not sure that
I've had enough distance from them
yet to actually pick the
one that I love the best.
I am writing the third
one right now.
It's about Wheezer and I said it's
kind of a mixture of Bring it On,
the cheerleading movie, Fringe
that show on Fox where they go
to alternate realities
and Silence of the Lambs.
[Laughter] And it's for the
middle grade 8 to 12 year olds.
[Laughter] I'm sorry.
Somebody should punch
me in the face.
Did you have another question?
Okay, alright.
Thank you.
You're a very good looking kid.
Yes.
>> Where did the idea of the
scenes in the book come from?
>> Michael Buckley: I'm
sorry what was the question?
>> Where do the ideas from the
scenes in the book come from?
>> Michael Buckley:
Where do my ideas come
from in the scenes of the book?
Well you know I sort of see the
book, almost like it's a movie.
And I sort of just transcribe
what I'm seeing my head.
The way I visualize it is very
much like what you might see
if you went to see a movie.
I even -- actually I
do this terrible thing.
My wife gets this horrible
magazine called Us Weekly.
And what I do is, stars
they're just like us.
And -- except they're not.
So what I do is I cast the book
sometimes, so like if I'm going
to write about Prince Charming
I'll try to find a picture
of like Hugh Grant, who I often
think of like Prince Charming.
And I cut it out and I put it
up on the wall and then like,
I always think of like Kate
Beckinsale as Snow White.
She's so hot.
[Laughter] Did I say that out loud?
So, I put pictures of
her up there and then
when the police come
I go straight to jail.
[Laughter] But that sort of helps me
cast the book and it helps me sort
of visualize it and
that's kind of how I do it.
Thank you.
Yes?
>> How much research do you have to
do before writing The Sisters Grimm?
>> Michael Buckley: Well you know
what I had to do a lot of research.
I was under the impression
that I actually knew something
about fairytales because
I had seen all the movies.
I was wrong.
When I was growing up we got most
of our fairytale stories from Disney
and a very good example is the
movie they made called Pinocchio.
Most of us have seen that movie.
It's really cute.
He's got that little dancing cricket
and the cricket gives him advice.
But in the book, which is
very different from the movie,
Pinocchio kills the cricket
on page 5 with a hammer.
And a friend of mine made
me read this and I was like,
"Kent that can't be true.
That can't be true."
And I started to realize there
was a lot going on in fairytales,
especially the stories that
I didn't know anything about.
And so I had to do a lot of reading
and writing at the same time.
And in the process I became
a huge fan of fairytales.
Yeah. Alrighty.
>> Hi. Can you tell us about
Snow White's story before it had
been changed?
You know about the
character or the margins.
>> Michael Buckley: You are
totally ruining this for everyone.
>> Well I mean in a future book.
>> Michael Buckley: Well in --
alright I'll just tell
you I don't care.
[Laughter] I already
got my advance spent.
[Laughter] In The Sisters
Grimm there's a --
Snow White is caught up in a story
that she doesn't even know she's in.
In fact, one of the ideas
is that Snow White's mother,
the wicked queen rewrote the story
of her life taking out a very,
very bad person out of her life
that she had been forced to marry
and literally creating Prince
Charming out of nothing
to be the husband that
she wanted for him.
So what you're going to find out in
the very last Sisters Grimm book is
that -- oh it's terrible.
But I'm writing this
thing called N.E.R.D.S.
and it's just really great.
But you're going to find out
about Prince Charming's brother
who is the very bad guy.
His name is Prince Atticus,
isn't that a scary name.
And you're going to find out
how this all works together
and we're going allow Snow White
to sort of get a hold of herself
for the first time in the series.
So I really love writing about her.
She's a really strong
female character.
She reminds me a lot of my grandma.
And -- except for the kung fu.
And -- but I do really enjoy her.
Does that answer the -- okay cool.
>> Thank you.
>> Michael Buckley: You're welcome.
Alright, Mr. Man.
>> Okay I was wondering.
You said there would be a last
Sisters Grimm, that's awful
but how many books are
going to be in the series
like how many are there going to be?
>> Michael Buckley: Well there's
only going to be nine in the series.
But if you guys keep building
it I think I could milk it
for at least two or
three more books.
[Laughter] Yes.
And then -- and it'll be like --
what's that book about the cats?
There's like 70,000 cats.
Yeah I'll just do it like that.
>> If you could have any nerdy
superpower what would it be?
>> Michael Buckley: Oh
that's a good question.
I'm trying to think of
myself when I was a kid.
And I don't know if
there's a super power here,
but when I was kid
there was an actor.
His name was Joey Laurence.
And Joey Laurence had a haircut
that required a Tupperware bowl.
You would put the bowl on his head
and you would cut around it so that
if you hung upside down you could
put a bowel of cereal in your head.
And I think that -- and I had
that haircut for a very long time
or maybe when I was 18
and I had a mullet, yeah.
That was great.
Girls loved it.
Maybe something like the mullet, and
it's like octopus arms and it comes
out and makes you party
in the back and business
in the front kind of thing.
I'm not sure.
How am I doing on time?
Oh she's just shaking her head.
Oh the two minute warning.
Oh we have three minutes.
Cool okay.
Oh well maybe I'll
just go on forever.
How about you sir.
By the way you're very good looking.
All of you are great looking kids.
>> How did you come up with what
N.E.R.D.S. actually stands for?
>> Michael Buckley: Well you
know what I actually had help.
My wife is a much smarter
person then I am
and in fact my wife actually
helped me coin the phrase,
"ever after" from The Sisters Grimm.
She is like really smart except
for the part where she married me.
That was big misstep I think.
But -- so she kind of
worked it out with me
and we finally figured
out how to do it.
I was trying to do it so it was
G.E.E.K.S. and I could only get
as far as like Government Espionage
and then I didn't know
what the next E was.
Then I tried D.O.R.K.S.,
Department of --
and then I couldn't get
any further than that.
That was the one that
worked the best.
So -- okay yes.
>> What made you make Sabrina be
in like all the Sister Grimm books?
>> Michael Buckley: This is a story
that I don't want my wife to hear.
Sabrina and Daphne actually --
Daphne is based on an
old girlfriend I had.
Her name was Renee Hoff,
and Renee was a very happy,
very full of energy and
just so super sweet.
But she had this older sister who
was super grouchy all the time.
And they fought like cats and dogs
except if somebody else picked
on them, and then they would fight
because they were from Jersey.
[Laughter] So those two
characters are really based
on people I really knew.
And I think we have time
for one or two more, yeah.
>> When Huck is first introduced
your books it's this nasty kid
who burps and farts and
does all this gross stuff.
>> Michael Buckley:
Yeah he's awesome.
>> But slowly in the Magic and
other Misdemeanors they get married.
And you start seeing Huck
like going into puberty
because he likes Sabrina.
How did you transition from this
kid who just lives in the wild
with the sloughs for fun to
some kid who's growing up?
>> Michael Buckley: This
is a really great question.
Thank you.
[Laughter] I don't
know how to answer it.
[Laughter] Well you know Huck is
like he great anti-hero of my story.
He's sort of like the Hans Solo of
the Sisters Grimm and he did start
out much more despicable but you
know this is the truth in life.
And this is really for the boys.
It doesn't matter how terrible
you are, how gross you are,
how much of a loser you are,
you will meet a woman
and she will fix you.
[Laughter] Alright guys.
I'm sorry we're out of time.
Did you have fun?
Alright. Thank you so much.
[Laughter]
>> This has been a presentation
of the library of congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.